[Music]
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 209 of the
askgaryvee show
we continue with the Facebook live
concept which means the questions will
be coming in the comment section
India will connect and as you can see we
have a guest again which excites me
India how are you doing then you just
said right before camera that you were
excited yeah about the show and I showed
you really excitement you said no not
really I was just kidding as I said I
was excited in a very dull voice right I
wasn't excited that was just how you
roll that's my man
why don't you tell the Vayner nation who
you are yeah and and then we'll get into
the show and I hear in the adjuster for
me you're gonna ask the first question
which excites me so I'm ready to go it's
a good day
Stephan drilled strong zoom in here if
you can get it
Stephan elbowed me today in basketball
so I continue to be injured I had a
blackout luckily I was traveling because
the black eye we got really bad you got
it in your world
I try not to have you ever really been
injured um I've had a concussion which i
think is probably as bad as a injury z21
but nothing major I'm a NASCAR driver my
name is Landon Cassill I Drive the
number 38 car in the NASCAR Sprint Cup
Series so that's a big deal of my life
it's crazy yeah so what before we get
into the show
what about two two minutes on that like
where were you born
like I always said you know 20 with
NASCAR I always think that you have to
be in the game at like waiter 5 or 6 or
7 to get to that kind of level is that
true like you drive them yeah I mean so
I mean I yeah honestly though it
wouldn't grow up
I grew up in Iowa I'm free I'm from
Cedar Rapids Iowa but I mean I think in
anything you have to get your 10,000
hours in so but I grew up video game
Live Well theory yeah absolutely and I
just lived and breathed racing but I
grew up in a car business so it's kind
of around it dad and uncle gearheads
would love cars and
start out in go-karts and just chill is
I just live for it in high school I
didn't really go to any school dances
I've worked on my race card every day
yeah I raced my senior year of high
school I raced in over 70 races across
the country and a nice time died but by
that time you understand that you were
capable of being a NASCAR driver I think
it was like age 15-16 is when so like
prior to 15 16 it was what I wanted to
do and I just I was young and stupid and
just knew I was going to do it I didn't
know how right you know what I mean like
I was just doing it I can't work on my
car every single day I traveled and race
two three times a week and that was it
and I just knew somehow was me a NASCAR
driver and it became real when I was
like 15 16 and I was actually getting
like national media attention in the
racing world I had signed with an age
and when I was 15 years old and I
actually had manufacturers approaching
me at the time to come test for them to
see what I was capable of and so when I
was 16 I did a test with Chevrolet and I
got signed through that anyway it was a
test with a bunch of different drivers
in it who eventually Ray was a part of
this test Indy 500 champion like there
was some legit drivers in this deal and
and I came out towards the top of this
test I got a contract from Hendrick
Motorsports which is a powerhouse yep
and I was Jimmie Johnson's test driver
for five years going straight out of
high school and that's what launched my
professional career as a driver so
during that five years I raced like part
time in the NASCAR Xfinity series I won
the Rookie of the Year which is kind of
like the second level yep - the Sprint
Cup Series and and that kind of built my
resume testing for Hendrick the in the
industry even though I wasn't racing
full-time it built a resume for me that
that teams look to me and they're like
we know this guy's driving good cars he
knows how to drive them and I started to
get opportunities with small teams that
were under fun
that that were in a shortage of drivers
yeah but so yeah so I got opportunities
to drive for these small teams and since
then I've just kind of been there
working my way up and I don't know how
long have you been in the Sprint Series
so my first start was 2010 okay so six
years going on six years and this is my
actual happen you end up here like you
and maybe your best friends or ever
second-best yes I manage that social
media friends show how did my content
first kind of hit your radar so I have a
friend in Charlotte his name is Caleb
Clark and he's a fashion designer yep he
owns a brand called enemy to fashion
okay and and he's someone that I've
always looked up to on the creative side
of things he's just always ahead of the
curve when it comes to just knowing
what's going on
yep and and when he introduced me
introduced me to you I think I realized
what secret is but really kayla has been
around a long time him and I work
together he was at an agency that
represented me when I was 15 and he was
their creative director and so now he's
a he's an entrepreneur and a self-made
man very good all right so what's the
first question well man in your world
and in in social media marketing taking
your expertise yes and applying it to my
business model yes which is athlete
independent contractor because I'm not
represented by a players union I'm not
represented by you know the NFL or NBA
you know I'm a NASCAR driver but
essentially I'm responsible for my own
brand I'm responsible for my own
revenues so the revenue comes in with
the logos in the car yep and and then
appearance fees yep and on the track now
the low of us on the court on the car
improve the performance on the track and
vice versa absolutely right chicken that
game exactly so the question is what
would I do if I were you yeah how do i
how do we how do i create a better
platform platform value proposition
or I want other partners i 100% believe
that you should execute the dailyvee
execution I think there is an enormous
amount of people who are watching right
now NASCAR is a humongous religion
I didn't say sport it's a humongous
humongous management and I believe that
there are some thousands of people that
would watch your 17 to 22 minute long
short as in fact let's you know we
wouldn't really done this yet this is a
good opportunity to what I'm about to do
this in the comments section on Facebook
and YouTube
if you are what you call your guys self
Stefan and videographer yeah great if
you're an aspiring videographer sorry I
mean I know I know I said if you were
aspiring and you're young and you're a
hustler and I would assume you this
would probably make even more sense
maybe this is not exactly how it ends up
happening but you love NASCAR I would
tell you and by the way I'm kind of
jumping to conclusions you might not
want the human being following you
around two hours a day on the camera but
I truly believe that what we're doing
with dailyvee right now is very much no
different than what I did in 1996 by
doing e-commerce or what I get by doing
a YouTube show back in 2006 that this
television like content vlogging and
Casey and many many other people did it
before before I did I think what the the
hardcore day-in-the-life
version of it though I think is quite
powerful the number one thing I would do
I truly believe that and so it's funny
you're sitting here I would almost even
use this as an analogy but but I used a
different one without you sitting here
but the first two where you sit in the
NASCAR world
I think the tenth man on an NBA team
right now to execute this model would
fundamentally be one of the five most
popular players in the NBA in three
years if he had the right personality
and the and was a good guy and had the
right it's just for repelling the hell
is Kim Kardashian right like what like
the story like it's the story of that
world and that's like
[Music]
every reality TV star it's just
storytelling and I think that's what you
should do I think it's very black and
white I'm very proud that I'm creating a
blueprint that I think is replicatable
and I think that that's what you should
I don't love that I think it would
change your world I think you're right I
think you're right I'll double down on
that and I mean and the biggest thing
you need to figure out is is what access
they have I sue a lot I've been through
you know I've been to Pocono I think
that's where you go
yeah I went to my father was the
marketing guy that you let young guns
years and years ago and so like you know
like people are filming there all the
time like as long as somebody can have
the right access and it's the real
stories right
like everybody sees Sunday or Saturday
right sad like what about Tuesday like
something you know stopping in a plane
driving around the cut like that's the
real stuff no I mean I like that ya know
I'll double down on that cuz that's
that's been on my mind and it was very
good at snapchat this is the first time
that was that was a huge hit I mean I
was really successful and just like you
said I just told a story over the course
of my day where I'm saying I'm double
down on that is you know like you said
leave a comment find me somehow unless
let's make this happen though no you're
gonna do a little bit of work we're easy
actually we'll do the work for you
somebody here on this team will set you
the two links to the Facebook in the
YouTube and there are hopefully 30 to 50
people in the comment section saying me
I can afford there's people now I'm sure
that I will follow your free beer equity
for free for a while like I don't know
what I can tell you for sure that if
you're lucky enough that you're a young
kid hustler let's try to get exposure
for access to being behind the scenes in
NASCAR it's gonna change your career
outcome I think it's an absolute barter
exchange I'm not trying to get you guys
to do free work even though I do it all
the time and believe in it I have no
idea of what you if you do have the
ability to pay something travel cost to
send the other thing but that's exactly
what I would do and I would be so pumped
to watch SportsCenter in 70 months of
the story of you that you did this and
to know it's all started right here
right now
no really that's like my fully hey SP
and I fully expect the first scene of
the e60 to start right here right now
okay I'll win next year's Daytona 500
yes I applaud Kasparov really stepping
up their social media game recently I
mean what areas do you guys think that
they could improve or suggest on them to
improve so what's your point of view but
exact you're right I don't have as much
contacts
I think it is what's happening but the
top stars the top 10 guys right now how
are they rolling in social anybody in
that top 10 crew you can do and that
thing you want to call out or not yeah
no I mean I think they're doing they're
doing good I mean is it your
appreciation with the driver you hear
people talking about it yeah you know in
my opinion the leader of the pack is
Dale jr. which he's I mean I said it I
even remembered that from Mountain Dew
we're on Mountain Dew like for 40 years
ago I knew it was in this world toward
it which you know that that that folson
is lapped because the nascar gravitates
towards him the smartest fans love him
of course but what I appreciate about
Dale Junior's I feel like he's got smart
people around him that have taken
advantage of that and and they have
gotten him very well educated on how to
be on Twitter and in getting into
Instagram and you know they've got a
radio show and podcast and and he's
doing a really really good job that's
awesome
you know that the I feel like the
challenges or is that there's a group
probably a group of drivers that are
just from a generation that just don't
show you to they just think they've made
their living racing cars for a long time
they they're their form of sponsored
relations is different pearance --is and
the things I've been doing over 20 years
that's right so so for them to adapt to
snapchat Twitter I mean they're all on
Twitter but it's a matter of what are
you doing it is
yeah and what about NASCAR's a-hole do
you know and I think NASCAR has has
taken a very serious move at social
media recently whether it's you know
like we talked about the snapchat like I
took over their snapchat like there's
snapchat story on the race weekend is
phenomenal like I would love to see more
during the week and see what you know
what else is going on I would I would
even love to see and I NASCAR offices I
am like I honestly think that that's
your white space for your you know daily
vlog that you're about to do soon yeah I
can't wait
I fully expect it to be live within two
weeks yeah there's no reason really
right there's plenty of meze in there we
just got to get my wife's permission
we're going to get us fine yeah what's
your wife's name Caitlin Caitlin you
have a different sports guys here is
awesome what did you guys think about
the NCAA in their policies athletes well
they kind of have a right look
everybody's got anyway what do you think
about their ethics and uh yeah how are
you gonna integrate that into the
episode of the video you did it yeah you
had it put another shell the Topkapi of
it may not man talent uh so I think that
um I look I think this is a hotbed issue
I think plenty people say well they get
their school paid for you know me
personally Gary thinks it's complete
horseshit I think every college athletes
should be paid the period of the story I
think the universities exploit it
aggressively
it feels very communistic I'm not a fan
of it I think that the athletes should
be paid and that's how I feel about it
very very simple very very binary but I
think it's a taboo issue like I have a
lot of
they get mad at me when we drink a glass
of wine on this issue but they get the
college paid for this time the other
thing to me it's just economics like
they're you know they're making
trillions of dollars on these kids
performances these kids are being
treated like professional athletes these
kids are not going to class these guys
are practicing 40 then let the practice
schedules of these professional athletes
especially at the tiers where the TV
deals are college men's college
basketball you know women's college
basketball men's college football like
you know I mean softball on ESPN now
like they keep big building bigger and
bigger schedules like they're being
treated like professional athletes and
they are not being compensated that way
and an unbelievable majority of them
never make it to the professional level
and ever are able to cash in on all the
dollars did drop in the university so I
I conditioned be pained I'm very I'm
pretty emotional about it for them but
it is what it is there's plenty of
things that upset me you thought so
never I don't know I like I don't think
I agree with you as binary if you
describe it as straightforward but I
think I could easily be weighted that
way but I look at it as you know
universities is primary number one needs
to be a place of higher education I
didn't go to college I wish I did yeah
I'm fortunate that I get to make my
living
yeah you know that actually made it
making a living driving yeah but you
know III it concerns me like if they if
they set up a way to you know start
paying football players the effects of
the ninety nine percent of them that
don't make it professionally and what
they did during their time in college
when they were making $50,000 a year
you're playing professional college
football yeah and not going to class
because that's not because they were
making their living and now all of a
sudden they didn't make it you know and
so I'm a little worried of some of the
common topic their problem is from my
standpoint that's a romantic point of
view because those same kids are not
going to calc class anyway they're not
pumping out at the University of
Michigan and going on to have these
illustrious careers because of their
education first of all I have my own
problems with college to begin with yeah
you've been getting professional
athletes like person that goes to
Michigan and leaves with a degree
reality in today's marketplace is a
whole nother issue we don't enough time
for this because I can get really about
this I think that the thing that's
absolutely dead on that you're so right
about it as like the cornerstone of the
whole argument is they're making hand
over fist size the sceen contract with
ESPN that you know these rules were
implemented in time when these
universities we're not making anywhere
close to these dollars it's become
anything you know show that our show
kind of mini it's a great Russian saying
it's very basic it's like everything is
great when it's balanced for 1961 the
amount of cotton money colleges we're
making on these athletes more in it the
universe karma balance fairness today I
mean you have a star plus Johnny Manziel
Texas A&M jerseys were sold mm-hmm I
mean anyway you promised aside from
teaching money and marketing tricks do
you have any regarding love so thank you
yes adorable my advice on love is very
similar to my by some I actually think
my business advice is actually my life
advice if you really unwind it
I think 5149 really matters and that's
more relationship now than love I think
that you know I would say the magic is
in the gray I think that's how love is
like it's not calculated like you know
it's it's it's just gonna happen in a
lot of times in a lot of ways so I
actually think all the advice I gave
actually execute to a love John I think
the relationship part is more
interesting to me the 5149 the listening
and counterpunching a lot of those
things the way I think about customer
and business relationships are very much
the way I think of relationships in
general and that's how I've rolled as
far as like the falling in love part the
serendipity it's very similar to like
the things I think about business where
you can't control what you can control
and don't be crippled by it that would
probably be my biggest advice I advise
very men yeah I'm going on four years
yeah yeah it's I think you you want
someone
this conflict as an addition to you you
know I mean my wife is everything that I
lack yeah I mostly you know I'm being so
romantic but like in so many ways it's
the cliche that everybody says it is I
mean you know I look at my wife and and
she's capable of so many things that I'm
not capable that's why I need her in my
life
so I mean my marry my mom yeah yeah you
married my mom yeah my wife and my mom
have a lot a lot of similarities other
than my wife is very organized and
structured and my mom's not other than
that a lot of the personalities are
similar interesting you know I think the
mom is the North Star for guys that they
go either hardcore to the left or right
my dad married the anti they also
generational thing like they didn't
escapes all right let's go India I was a
good question no how do you from gr I
know this real name how do you feel that
social media has shaped NASCAR is it
good or bad as a driver or good as bad
as a fan also um well so our entire
business model is supported by corporate
support so yeah yeah I guess that's true
so you want to show your personality but
you but you can you it's easy to
second-guess your personality if like
well what if I have a sponsor that isn't
gonna like your your point it's even
further right like you know football
player shows a split personality right
you know well in actually on track to
the death where I say our whole business
model is supported by corporate support
is because it takes that to run the
NASCAR team like we can't survive just
off the prize money we have to have
corporate support or somebody has to
underwrite the program yeah so so that's
that's kind of is there in that scarf or
some billionaires that have underwrite
you some programs oh yeah absolutely
absolutely I mean there's there's plenty
of them you know and I mean my team is
uh our car owner is is a racer you know
he's
he's not making money off of our races
he's a racer and so you know we search
hard for sponsors because because it
helps our team and because we've got a
passion for the sport we want to grow
the sport won't grow our partners but
the end of the day my car owner you know
he steps off you know what at what
percentage is it the 25 percent and down
like actually in the bottom third you're
like financial teams yeah how much time
do you think the driver and the core two
or three top people spend on the
business part of like hustling for
sponsoring like what percentage of what
percent of time do you spend on thinking
about trying to secure doing the parents
like hustling and ice I I mean I see
everybody thinking about it I don't know
I struggle it is hard to apply it
sometimes if I don't do enough I think
too much you probably don't do enough we
you know I travel Thursday to Sunday so
by the time I'm can sit down in my
office can actually act on thoughts and
can do things I'm on a plane and head to
the racetrack where I have to focus on
the race car right so so there's
definitely a struggle of balance in
executing right you know that's where we
talk about content generation and things
like that like man you know for me this
struggle isn't I guess what content do I
create is how do i execute it how what
if what if when one of driver wins a big
race that's a bottom 20% financial like
how rare is that it's it's pretty rare
but NASCAR is really there changing the
rules in terms of how the cars are built
to help accommodate more parity more
parity because it's the greatest thing
the NFL did yeah absolutely I mean it's
it's hard you know people don't realize
how much goes into the race card and how
many engineers it takes and how many you
know what what adding finding a secret
bend in your body that adds 50 pounds of
downforce I can feel that that's just
that's this right here right pushing
down on your car I can feel that
the car it makes me go faster well you
know some of the big teams there's just
so much more capable of finding shorter
five six seven eight nine ten more of
those things so if you don't realize I
ate you know that that lack of parity is
something that NASCAR is very aware of
that they that they're trying to improve
and that that's what helps teams like
mine but I mean I mean the day we have a
unfuck sponsorship person on your team
or do you yeah yeah we've got a
marketing staff yeah cool interesting
stuff
I enjoyed question today you get to ask
question of the day oh man yeah you get
to ask the vaynernation any question you
want and they have to answer it it's the
rule all right
if you were a NASCAR fan at one point in
your life
why aren't you now oh interesting so
you're asking the small subgroup
yeah well the vaynernation or the people
that are in vaynernation that that knew
that know about NASCAR how about me I
have only why's it out a little bit well
if you know about now you're not early
in why are you right now not currently a
NASCAR yeah why are you having morning
ones whatever have you ever watched
NASCAR don't know no feelings here not
really is that that's the guy you're
targeting yeah I've seen it on time you
watch that race right why if you have to
watch my words no no no no no one one
one one got it because we scheduled the
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get the link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that